si joe biden poursuit sa tournée
européenne outre atlantique ces faits et
gestes ne manque pas d'interpeller
l'ancien président américain donald
trump
la réunion du g7 le week end dernier et
les échanges entre le locataire de la
maison blanche emmanuel macron ont
notamment provoqué son courroux pour
plus de précisions on retrouve tout de
suite notre reporter thomas abonnés en
direct de washington bonsoir thomas
qu'est ce qui a provoqué la colère de de
donald trump et bien comme nous donald
trump a vu les différentes images qui
ont été diffusées des différentes
rencontres et les différentes
discussions lors du g7 où on a pu voir
emmanuel macron et joe biden un très
proche mettant en scène une complicité
une proximité même qui a évidemment un
sens politique alors si on ne nie pas le
fait que les deux présidents puisse
avoir de bonnes relations si rapidement
on sent que ces images visait surtout à
servir le discours avancés par les deux
hommes à savoir l'amérique est de retour
plus proche que jamais de ses alliés
écouté par exemple les propos d'
emmanuel macron dans cette vidéo qu'il a
lui-même posté sur son compte twitter
pour tous ces problèmes nous avons
besoin de coopération et je pense que
c'est formidable que le président
américain fasse partie du club et qu'il
soit très désir de coopérer et je pense
que ce que vous démontrez c'est que le
leadership c'est un partenariat
les chick histoire de chiffres vous avez
entendu c'est super d'avoir un président
qui fait partie du club et qui a le
souci de vouloir coopérer bien cette
phrase a particulièrement retenu
l'attention d'un observateur de marque
puisqu'il s'agit de donald trump
l'ancien président américain étant privé
de ses réseaux sociaux c'est par le
biais d'un communiqué qu'il a vivement
réagi directement aux propos de madame
macron écouter
lui et beaucoup d'autres dirigeants
avant lui en france et dans toute
l'europe arnaquer les états unis comme
jamais auparavant
il aime byden parce que maintenant ils
seront autorisés à reprendre leurs
anciennes méthodes d'escroquerie
si j'étais un dirigeant de ces pays moi
aussi je préférais byden au président
trump des critiques très virulentes
visant notamment à s'attaquer à la
diplomatie naissante de joe biden mais
ces attaques ciblent aussi emmanuel
macron avec qui les relations étaient
parfois compliquées entrent donc
l'ancien président américain et le
président en français on se souvient
d'abord de ce qui était présenté comme
une relation spéciale avec ce fameux
dîner à la tour eiffel où il y avait les
deux présidents entourés de leurs
compagnes on se rappelle également que
macro avait tenté de se placer en
interlocuteurs européens privilégié de
donald trump mes désaccords avaient
ressurgi notamment à l'occasion de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
c'était en 2018 à new york notamment sur
la question du changement climatique et
puis il ya évidemment le tempérament en
tempétueux pardon de donald trump
alors évidemment on peut comprendre
qu'elle macron puisse préférer le calme
de joe biden mais il faudra voir sur la
durée si l'entente n'était que de façade
ce week-end ou s'il y aura de réelles
avancées sur des dossiers concrets et à
suivre donc
merci thomas bonheur direct de
washington